I HAVE TO SAY, ONE OF MY
FAVORITE STORIES OF THE LAST
WEEK INVOLVED A YOUNG LADY
WHO TOOK AN EARLY MORNING
EXCURSION TO RETRIEVE AN
UNSAVORY RELIC.
OR IN LAYMAN'S TERMS, THAT
SISTER TOOK THE CONFEDERATE FLAG
DOWN.
>> BREE NEWSOME SCALED THE 30
FOOT POLE AND DESCENDED WITH THE
FLAG IN HAND.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
WELCOME BAD FLAG SNATCHER
BREE NEWSOME.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
ON THE SHOW.
COME ON OUT.
HAVE THAT SEAT RIGHT THERE.
THERE WE GO.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Larry: I NOTICED WHEN YOU
TWEETED YOU WERE EXCITED TO
BE ON THE SHOW, TO SHARE
SOME MINT JULEP WITH ME.
>> YES!
>> Larry: KIND OF A LITTLE
TOAST.
>> AND DISCUSS A DISCUSSION
OF REMOVING THE FLAG.
>> Larry: EXACTLY AM SO HERE
IS WHAT I WANT TO HE NO.
HOW MUCH PLANNING, LIKE WENT
INTO THAT.
DID YOU HAVE LIKE A POLE IN
YOUR BACKYARD, TO PRACTICE
ON.
>> WELL, YEAH, IT WAS ABOUT
TEN OF US WHO PULLED THE
WHOLE THING TOGETHER
INCLUDING FOLKS  DOWN
IN SOUTH CAROLINA WHO COULD
LIKE ACTUALLY GO DOWN THERE
AND LOOK AT THE SCENE, SEE
WHAT ALL WHAT BE INVOLVED,
WHAT ROLES WOULD BE
REQUIRED.
AND SO THEN BY THE TIME WE
CAME TO GET IT, SOME OF
THOSE LOGISTICS HAD BEEN
LAID OUT AND IT WAS JUST A
MATTER OF WHO WAS GOING TO
FILL WHAT ROLES INCLUDING
CLIMBING THE POLE.
SO I WAS LIKE I WILL DO T
HAD I CLIMBED A POLE BEFORE
NO, BUT LET'S DO IT.
>> SO THERE WAS A WHOLE
GROUP AND YOU SAID WAIT,
WAIT.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, YEAH, I
MEAN, WE WENT THROUGH IT AND
OF COURSE WE HAD TO DISCUSS
THAT THE TWO ROLES, ONE OF
CHRIPING THE POLE AND ONE OF
BEING AT THE BOTTOM AND
WATCHING GUARD, THOSE TWO
PEOPLE MIGHT AN RESTED.
>> Larry: HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE ON THE SCENE DURING
THE --
>> ABOUT NINE OF US.
>> Larry: THERE WERE NINE
PEOPLE THERE.
I -- KNOW THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: THERE WAS A
GROUP OF YOU THAT DID THIS
TOGETHER.
>> YEAH T WAS COORDINATED.
>> Larry: DID YOU ALL WORK
IN YOUR CORE, LIKE AT THE
SAME TIME.
THAT IS WHAT I WOULD HAVE TO
DO.
SO WHAT WENT THROUGH YOUR
MIND THE MOMENT YOU HAD THAT
FLAG?
DID YOU REALIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS OR WERE
YOU JUST KIND OF-- LIKE GOD,
I CAN SEE MY HOUSE FROM HERE.
WHAT DID THAT FEEL LIKE.
>> IT WAS JUST LIKE THIS
REALLY AMAZING FEELING OF
LIKE MISSION ACCOMPLISHED,
YOU KNOW.
I MEAN ONE OF THE HARDEST
POINTS THAT I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT IS JUST GET BEING 15
FEET UP THE POLE AND I KNEW
ONCE I GOT THAT FAR UP I WAS
PRETTY MUCH CLEAR TO MAKE IT
UP THERE.
ONCE I GOT UP THERE AND WAS
ABLE TO UNHOOK THE FLAG.
>> HIGH ENOUGH THAT NO ONE
COULD GRAB YOU.
>> EXACTLY.
ONCE I GOT UP THERE AN
GRABBED IT, IT WAS JUST LIKE
YES, TAKE ME TO JAIL.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: AND WHEN YOU WERE
ABOUT HALFWAY UP, DID
YOU-- WHEN THE CAPITOL
POLICE SHOWED UP.
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: WERE YOU SCARED AT
THAT MOMENT?
WHAT DID THAT FEEL LIKE?
>> NO, NOT REALLY BECAUSE I WAS
OUT OF REACH.
IT WAS KIND OF THIS AWKWARD
THING OF THEM BEING TO COME
DOWN AND ME JUST BEING LIKE,
NO.
YOU KNOW.
>> Larry: WERE THEY PRETTY
COOL ABOUT IT?
>> YEAH, I MEAN CLEARLY I
HAD RUINED THEIR DAY, I
MEAN-- YOU KNOW, I WAS
LIKE-- .
>> Larry: BUT OOPS, SORRY
GUYS.
>> SORRY FOR THE
INCONVENIENCE.
>> Larry: SOME PEOPLE
COMPARED TO YOU ROSA PARKS,
CALLED YOU LIKE A SUPERHERO,
RIGHT SO HERE IS WHAT I WANT
TO DO.
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH A
PROPER SUPERHERO NAME FOR
YOU.
OKAY.
SO THE ASCENDER,
SOUL POLE, KIND OF COOL,
SOUNDS LIKE FROZEN A LITTLE
BIT.
SISTER SWIFTER OR QUEEN BREE
QUESTION ONE, QUEEN BREE?
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: ACTUALLY, I THINK
THE PROPER SUPERHERO NAME IS
BREE NEWSOME.
THERE YOU GO.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Larry: SO WE ALSO HAVE AN
AWARD WE WANT TO GIVE YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> Larry: IT'S TITLED THE
BREE NEWSOME AWARD.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WORKS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T
HAVE IT HERE BUT WE PUT IT
IN A PLACE THAT MIGHT BE
EASY FOR YOU TO GET.
SO IF WE CAN JUST
SHOW-- YEAH, SO YOU CAN GRAB
IT.
NO, NO, NO.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
NO, NO, THE BREE NEWSOME
AWARD, UNBELIEVABLE WHAT SHE
DID.